on vous remercie d'être en direct avec
nous cette manifestation interdite a
quand même eu lieu et il ya eu du monde
on l'a vu pourquoi la police et la
préfecture n'ont pas réussi à empêcher
sa tenue
alors déjà il y avait vingt mille
manifestants donc ça fait du monde ça
fait beaucoup de policiers mobilisés
après il ya toujours des choses qu'on ne
comprend pas donc là la question à
savoir pourquoi ça n'a pas été empêchées
faudrait poser la question à monsieur
l'allemand à la préfecture de police
ce qu'il y avait quand même des
effectifs de police qui étaient déployés
à proximité les services de
renseignement avait bien précisé qu' au
rassemblement avec du monde
du coup après les questions de notre les
ordis rares chic c'est faut poser la
question des fois on ne les comprend pas
nous sur le terrain est d'après vous
pourquoi la police on vous dit qu'elle
était présente sur place n'a pas voulu
intervenir en amont est ce que vous
pensez qu'il peut y avoir des raisons
politiciennes derrière après s'il ya
vraiment des raisons il aurait pu
autoriser la manifestation c'est
toujours plus facile d'autoriser pour
avoir des contacts dans les chais les
manifestants et donner un message un peu
plus pacifique
et puis d'avoir aussi les effectifs
autour pour bien contrôler autorisé ces
contrôles et là c'était interdit donc
c'était quasiment incontrôlable ans avec
sale et mal se finir dès le début
quasiment donc après on ne sait pas
pourquoi n'est pas intervenu pourquoi
ces politiques us qui avaient assez de
monde de surplace déployé ce qu'ils
avaient peur de ce qui se passait aux
états unis et que ça fasse la même chose
en france
les explications sont à demander à
monsieur le préfet de police sur le
terrain on est un petit peu dépassé sire
que soit la manifestation est interdite
de placement là on fait tout pour
l'empêcher
soit elle est autorisée en l'encadré là
on était en dedans une situation ni l'un
ni l'autre ce qui était incompréhensible
d'un point de vue légal de rues fermées
pas de menaces selon vous est ce qu'il
ya eu un manque de moyens ou de volonté
politique
les moyens c'est qu'on les a il ya du
matériel qui était recommandée y compris
pendant le confinement
les dernières manifestations qu'on peut
avoir lieu on voit bien que les
policiers sont équipés donc là il ya une
fille plutôt politique est là après
l'aide gestion nous préférons les
gestions se passe calmement mais tu en
aurais préféré du coup que tout le cadre
légal derrière soit adaptée à la
situation
on a vu que la dispersion s'est fait
tardivement est ce qu'on peut parler
d'eux
gestion dernière minute la manifestation
où il va se faire tardivement façon les
gens qui étaient là savaient qu'ils
risquaient déjà de se prendre une amende
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas droit d'être
là donc forcément les gens étaient prêts
déjà aller à l'affrontement dans leur
tête pour une partie le rassemblement à
ramener du monde le quartier autour et
pas forcément facile non plus à
quadriller donc si les gens il ya des
roues ils peuvent partir à droite à
gauche
donc oui c'était prévisible de le faire
et après les débordements marne aurait
les collections place ont essayé de
faire au mieux mais une fois de plus
c'est quand les débordements arrive
qu'on nous donne l'ordre de réagir
plutôt que d'essayer de les prévenir en
amont pour pas qu'ils aient lieu donc
c'est une police de répression plutôt
que de prévention ce qui cause des
problèmes à la fois aux riverains
manifestants puis à mes collègues qui
prennent des risques d'aller se faire
blesser alors que si c'était fait en
amont et qu'on m'interdit nez sur les
fauteurs de troubles repérez cela se
passerait sans doute mieux merci
beaucoup alexandre langlois je rappelle
que vous êtes secrétaire général du
syndicat de police vivait merci à vous